and game maybe biryeo kids here 13  seconds plenty of time Nuggets down one  into burry here we go  ten seconds Murray - yo  [Applause]  Yogesh  [Applause]  [Applause]  he thought he got fouled he started to  go to the official  his teammates grounded that folded away  [Applause]  how did Millsap get out of there Scott  well that's good  he did get south  now you got one point to they deal he  got his arm slap he did get his arm slap  [Music]  remember the Nuggets have already used  their coaches challenge or they might be  able to replay that dougie was the last  lead Denver had that had to be early in  the first quarter  [Applause]  [Music]  you may want to think about here not  much time to pass a pass it so the  inbounder baby out of the play you got  it careful about the law inside you and  be